just cut back to London and about two
about to go into a meeting it and
they've got my they've got my billboard
here what's a blog like calling you blog
by the way what's a blog that's doing
all hands-on meeting with the team here
in London should be a lot of fun giving
a little update on where my mind's at
every time I go to the satellite offices
it's good to get peeps together I think
we've been more disciplined here in
London with all hands-on than we've been
in hey guys in Chattanooga and and LA
and I I want to fix that and so let's go
together
hello all right I have a really cool
thing about selling guys so I'm good at
it myself things people want and I mean
on an individual basis like I don't care
what Megan or I still want I just want
to know what it is and then I and it's
my job to work for all of you to build
the infrastructure to what you want I
don't care if you're like you could you
want to be like me great like work here
build leverage with me and then I'll
help you go do your thing like you want
to you know like you want you want to
like see every one of your child's you
know sporting events great like make
sure I know that and then we'll make
sure you end up in the right place where
you have enough flexibility to do that
while making enough to appease you
financially like I really have no horse
in the race of what anybody wants you or
client the answer your question is what
do they want now what do they want
/ what do we believe in is the far more
interesting part right so they want a
lot of [ __ ] we don't believe in so the
question becomes we need to stay really
passionate about what we believe in so
for example we could probably be
spending another five hundred million
dollars in media if I was willing to
waver on things that they want us to do
that I just don't want to do we could
hire three people who buy print from
group M and media con we could I just
don't want to I think it's finding our
niche of what we do while deploying and
executing things that we're passionate
about and capable of whether it's
influencer or marketplace social or
things of that nature but it starts with
knowing the reality like spending 17
hours on trying to convince or anybody
else to do something with us when we
could have already known that's not
gonna happen no matter what because it's
already locked in is what I want to do
we spend so many hours on ideological
points of view instead of selling to the
reality I spent in no time
on things that are not sellable so I
understand there your current clients
and it's what we have to work with but
it's up to the account team and to the
leadership to
me to make sure it's even a feasible
conversation because they'll take the
meeting and they'll yes you to death and
then they'll resize with [ __ ] cool about
10 minutes to get there yeah okay what
you going into a client meeting but just
had a really interesting conversation I
love people take the initiative to spark
conversations that are on the offense
I'm an offensive player [ __ ] defense
don't worry about what you think I care
about tell me what you care about let me
we got to it alright now that you're in
a meeting I am going for a coffee shop
yeah boy I wish that was filmed big
shout-out to uh Brno Mars big big big
fan Brno love your stuff your spam is
incredible headed to a helicopter to go
do a networking and speaking event at
Facebook is it at Facebook
not at Facebook but Facebook event and
meet some agencies partners and brands
and so that should be good little
helicopter back
this one's going there Dirac this one
was coming back not so I get sad when
peppers get crushed but I love peppers
and just when they get crushed the rock
I get super sad I try to get here once
every other month or so do client
meetings do meetings with the staff
about to go on a helicopter we got a
conference with Facebook that I'm
speaking at the meeting other business
partners and and other agency partners
and potential clients and shake a couple
hands of car clients so it's usually at
24 or 48-hour blitz of as much
vaynermedia stuff as possible when I get
to London its vaynermedia all the way
through and through yeah not right now
to look too tough out there
[Music]
how is the fly play was great yeah sure
yeah I mean it awesome great flight
countryside here
d-roc keep it tabs on me some horses
some helicopters beautiful great landing
a bunch of people with cameras which is
interesting in the background not quite
sure what's going on but let's go not to
give this talk here
Facebook off site with a bunch of people
in the industry and clients and
potential clients you know you know how
I do it state of the unions whether it's
in a hotel in Amsterdam or a conference
center in Anaheim or some bar near in
the countryside of London wherever I
need to do it I will spin it there's a
reason Woolworths went out of business
there's a wee reason iBM is not the
consumer technology leader it's all the
stuff we're living through I just don't
think we've grappled with how fast it's
a happening in the next 10 years this we
always talk about you brought up
Millennials it's not about Millennials
65 year old men is sitting next to me on
flights watching Star Wars on their
mobile device we like to say this is our
teenage children this is us there are 50
year olds in here who sent the poop
emoji last night this is us there's not
I don't know a single 42 year old female
that doesn't have a six-figure income in
her home that isn't living on Instagram
like what are we talking about what's
this future we talk about you act one
way when you live your real life and
then you have different points of view
when you put on your Jersey for your
firm that's just real
yes so vlog I like calling them vlog be
like vlog I hope the rock caught that
snippet I don't know how high quality or
low quality you got it the rock it's
just a consumer if you understand the
consumer bad it's amazing to me that me
with no connections no education to like
like nothing no money was able to always
win on the same game which is complete
and utter religion of the consumer of
what I do and then everything works at
it it's unbelievable we have a complete
disconnect so I would say your biggest
advantage is fresh eyes if you
understand the consumer not the ebody
not who you're gonna Eman you know how
you know you're not refer who you're
gonna M&A to three years of the actual
customer and that's why social is so big
for me was consumer insights at scale
for free it just took all my time 15
hours a day on Twitter and and Facebook
in two thousand six seven eight nine
just reading every single comment about
every single piece of content about
every single genre and then you get an
insight there's no quant and qual data
that beats really putting in the work
for a considerable piece of time in a
narrow field right so I would just spend
every waking moment that you can and
listen I like the dirt so I'm a meth
addict too there's different styles of
entrepreneurship whether it's you or
somebody very important that doesn't go
anywhere a deep understanding of the
consumer insight that is free not not a
company in the middle of the fire hoses
of the api's analyzing it so they can
make margin you with them and that's
where I think you can win that's what I
would do and that's why I always say
naive eyes I mean I didn't even know
anything about the agency world the
first four years nothing I couldn't
named CEO of Omnicom right now couldn't
name right so you know what I mean
but I sure know that eight-year-old
girls make slime you know all of you
give me so much credit for engaging and
listening and being with you but you
give me so much more than I'm giving you
because you're the punchline it's all
consumer focus the reason I don't pay
attention to my competition
it's not because I'm brash or cool
because it doesn't [ __ ] matter when
you're obsessed with the end consumer
bring them you why do you think I'm
asking you if two channels works because
I need to give you what you want
everybody talks about well if you listen
to consumer this yes of course you
can't only be about what the consumer is
you have to go through your lens but it
starts and ends with you guys and I will
always do actions that bring you the
most value because then I get value in
return 5149 that's the [ __ ] game till
the end biggest companies in the world
and for us little entrepreneurs
[Music]
this is car
just cut back to London and about two
about to go into a meeting and they've
got my they've got my billboard here
[Music]
it's going really well yeah it's going
really well I mean look I'm trying to
build a platform for my future business
behavior the key is building ninjas who
don't get romantic about anything other
than consumer attention and the
contextual creative that makes them do
something so what's interesting is we're
building but by the time we buy Peroni
it might be Alexa voice it might be a R
it might be some device that two girls
in Chelsea are inventing right now in
their basement so we're where my
challenge is for the people at Vayner is
for them to understand that if I start
at Vayner today we would be a voice shop
and you know and so that's the
interesting thing to navigate to come
here I think I've done a much better job
in last year I think I come here to
eighteen months ago I think everybody
understands okay we're not a
social-media shop then there's plenty
people think we are but no I mean 18
months ago I think everybody thought
that's what we were and now I think
people are like okay I just got off a
call gave some real hardcore feedback to
the team on my insights on how we pitch
in position vaynermedia at some level
that's my responsibility of structuring
and positioning our shop in the in the
right way and so that was a super good I
felt good about it had a bunch of
leaders on the call that I thought got
what I was saying and I think it's gonna
be disproportionately fruitful for being
or going forward so really productive
you know 20-minute call here in the
middle of the street at 11 p.m. in
London is is a call that is going to
move the business and I think more
leaders need to get into the dirt to
have these impact moments to build their
businesses especially when you're
running a big company
do you know where I'm going you got man
you get really well-made how are you
yeah good nice to see the city ride
[Music]
the thing with me starting this journey
and talent is the bobble was this big of
what I can do but what I've done and
what I've seen is this big that's right
and I've done this very well and now I'm
meeting people like yourself and other
people that I've met with and they're
like oh I'm doing this I'm doing this
I'm like you know I don't even thought
about that
I've been so busy doing this of course
I'm mastering this that like I mean like
no juicing content selling it to Asia
right and it's not even touching this
yeah this becomes available when you
become great at something like this the
problem for everybody right here is
they're trying to do all this before
they got great at this patience patience
[ __ ] patience vaynernation follow
this man will tag him up he's really a
worthwhile follow he's paying attention
he's executing that's what matters d-roc
execution
[Music]
I try to tell you this aside that we
should be there but you push away
[Music]